evergrand is asia's biggest issuer of
junk bonds it makes up a really hefty
chunk of chinese property bonds in the
offshore market now the worry is that if
we see any kind of messy collapse of
evergrand or even a default it could
threaten to destabilize both china's
financial markets and its credit markets
we've already started to see some of
that stress accelerating for chinese
property firms both in the credit
markets and in equity markets right now
which is the yields in credit the kind
of borrowing cost for other chinese
property firms is soaring as yields for
chinese junk rated offshore bonds rise
to their highest in about a decade ever
grand shares here at hospital the
companies would
suspended they are still suspended china
evergreen group's crisis has really
deepened in recent weeks
investors and analysts are watching very
very closely it's repayment schedule to
see whether evergrand can continue to
honor its upcoming debt obligations so
that includes things like dollar bond
coupons that bondholders say they are
yet to receive it may also include
another bond that's said to be
guaranteed by evergrand and another of
its units
so investors are watching for any sign
that beijing authorities will step in to
kind of ease the crisis at evergrand
either it might do that by somehow
managing the restructuring or potential
restructuring directly or if central
bank authorities choose to kind of
inject liquidity into the system or move
to try and ease any signs of stress
another thing investors are watching
very closely is evergren's imminent debt
repayments so that includes things like
coupons that are coming due on its
onshore and offshore bonds and it may
also include maturities that are coming
due on its opaque type of debts that
might not be widely known in the market
at the moment evergrand and another of
its unis shares are currently suspended
pending a so-called major transaction
now evergreen hasn't shared details of
what that transaction may be but
separately local media has reported that
hobson development which is another
property firm owned by a guangdong
billionaire another guangdong
billionaire that it has
mulling a decision to purchase a 51
stake in evergrand property management
unit and that might help ease some of
evergrass imminent cash worries
[Music]